soit remaniée mais comme un comme un
breton se sont bretons je pense que
c'est ça la véritable manière de
l'échiquier charles aznavour était
devenu un symbole pour toute la
communauté arménienne
un breton est breton et il est français
moi je suis heureux je suis français une
nationalité française mais une identité
arménienne une revendication partagée
par de nombreux arméniens à partir des
années 60 après le génocide de 1915 des
dizaines de milliers d'arméniens
trouvent refuge en france et s'intègre
discrètement mais dans les années 60
leurs petits enfants entendent bien
faire vivre l'arménie alors rayés de la
carte
seul moyen de résister à distance
conserver leur culture
et pour y parvenir des camps de vacances
sont mises en place
le but de ce camp d'abord c'était de
créer un foyer arméniens pendant les
vacances de pouvoir redonner à nos
jeunes
disons un peu du patrimoine arménien
particulièrement de l'histoire
arménienne et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
comme le fait mon camarade l'expliquent
actuellement la géographie de l'arménie
ce que beaucoup ignorent les générations
vont se succéder avec toujours cette
volonté de préserver la culture la clé
de voûte de l'identité arménienne la
langue une langue pratiquée dans
l'église grégorienne bonjour madame
bonjour père
comment allez vous ça va bien je vous
remercie mais aussi rapidement dans les
écoles arméniennes les jeunes arméniens
d'île de france dispose de deux grands
collèges
en plus du programme français officiel
jusqu'au baccalauréat
on leur y enseigne la langue et la
civilisation à venir
la presse arménienne aussi joue le rôle
de gardienne de la culture cette presse
n'a pas seulement commettons la presse
française
en france un rôle d'information de
débats de direction de l'opinion ou de
réflexion elle a tous ces rôles là mais
en plus elle a un rôle de maintien de
l'identité arménienne presse écoles
églises centre culturel le maintien de
l'identité arménienne est une forme de
résistance pour toute la diaspora
française alors que depuis 1991
l'arménie est devenu un état indépendant
les dernières générations ont la volonté
de conserver et de transmettre cette
culture choisi cette école aux diverses
raisons d'abord parce que c'est une
école arménienne et ça me tient à coeur
ça représente ma culture mon peuple mes
racines et je pense que c'est mon devoir
de ne pas oublier ne pas oublier tout ça
et de pouvoir ensuite de transmettre aux
générations futures
aujourd'hui en france le nombre
d'arméniens est estimé entre 600 milles
et 800000 personnes
[Musique]